تملك سياره من طراز محلي في ايران قد
يتطلب العمل اربعين شهره بالنسبه الى
اصحاب الدخل المحدود
اسعار دفعت عباس الى التنقل بين عده محال
واماكن لعله يجد واحده تتناسب مع قدرته
الماليه ولا حديث بين الزبون والبائع في
هذا المحل الا عن كيفيه سداد قيمه السياره
والبحث عن سبل للدفع تسهل عليهم امتلاكها
كنت اخطط لشراء سياره منذ ثلاثه اشهر
انتظرت قليلا على امل تراجع اسعارها الان
ارتفعت الى الضعف فكيف لمواطنين بدخل
محدود ان يحصل على سياره في ظل هذه
الزياده
الوضع غير جيد بالنسبه للمستهلك حتى لمن
يريد الاستثمار في السيارات ومن الصعب
حدوث استقرار في السوق بسبب الاوضاع
الحاليه
لتقلب سعر الدولار اثره في سوق المعاملات
اليوميه بايران ثم ان يرتفع سعره مقابل
العمله المحليه حتى تقفز معه اسعار جميع
المنتجات الاستهلاكيه من بينها السيارات
وفي بعض الاوقات ترتفع اسعارها بنسب اكبر
من نسب ارتفاع سعر صرف العملات الاجنبيه
تهاوي العمله المحليه مقابل الدولار لم
يكن لصالح المواطن الايراني اذ ان نحو
اربعه عشر مليون عائله غير قادرين على
امتلاك سياره
بعض المنتجات تحولت الى منتجات استثماريه
وليست استهلاكيه فقط بينها السيارات
واصبحت تخضع للمضاربه ما يؤدي الى ارتفاع
اسعارها وندرس ثم قانون ضريبي للحد من هذا
النوع من التعاملات الماليه
يعتقد عامه الايرانيين ان من اسباب غلاء
السيارات تلعب السماصره بالاسعار
لكن اخرين يرون ان القدره الانتاجيه
المحليه لا تلبي حاجه السوق وهناك من يقول
ان شركات محليه تسيطر على السوق وتفرض
اسعارها
تتحرك الحكومه الايرانيه لتطويق هذا الوضع
فتفرض نسبه محدده للزياده في الاسعار لا
تتجاوز
29% وتستعين ببورصه خاصه ببيع وشراء
السيارات تضمن شفافيه المعاملات ولا تغفل
من حساباتها فتح باب الاستيراد لزياده
العرض والحد من ارتفاع الاسعار ان كانت
السيارات المحليه الصنع لم تعد في متناول
شريحه كبيره من الناس هنا في ايران فان
اقتناء سياره من هذا الطراز الاجنبي صار
حلما لكن تبقى اعينهم على قرارات حكوميه
لعلها تحول حلمهم بامتلاك سياره الى حقيقه
الجزيره طهران